what's happening there reject nation
greg here john here we're gonna watch
some new rock stars today the mortal
kombat easter eggs and breakdown but
before we go into that we both got balls
balls balls say it's loud and proud
today's video is sponsored by manscaped
and if you've been on the internet at
all lately you know these guys are out
here holding it down with some of the
finest men's grooming products around
balls but since april is national
testicular cancer awareness month every
purchase at manscape.com contributes to
their we
save balls campaign the goal is to
spread awareness for men's health early
cancer detection and prevention as well
as support for folks who are affected by
testicular cancer it's easy to check
yourself
in fact you can do it right after you're
done shaving with the skin safe
lawnmower three and right before you
apply your crop
preserver ball deodorant that one's used
by me already i would put that down oh
i rubbed the cap the bottle on me to
learn how to check yourself i sound so
natural when i say that you can visit
manscape.com
tcs for more info and as always you can
save yourself 20
and free shipping at manscape.com when
you use our special code reel 20.
i type with my balls and it also goes to
support the testicular cancer society
so a big thank you again to manscaped
and seriously remember
to check yourself because testicular
cancer honestly is the most prevalent
form in males ages 15 to 35.
anyone with testicles really so
seriously get yourself checked
what i just turned
15 years old start checking those balls
clearly just shot that intro a couple
minutes ago am i right welcome back to
new rockstars i'm eric boss in mortal
kombat delivered the violent delights
and campy fan service i expected
as a past too young player of this game
who like luke hang in this movie i
really only knew how to sweep the leg
while my big brother used the
combo of a real life shoulder punch it
still kind of hurts
so i'm going to break down all the cool
visual details and references to the
games hidden throughout this film
spoilers ahead and here we go we open on
the compound of hanzo hasashi
future scorpion in 1617. now playing
hanzo in this movie is the legendary
hiroyuki sonata famous for many roles
but marvel fans might know him as
akihiko in avengers inn game these
opening images
very much on the gardening trowel used
by hanzo's wife harumi
this is actually called a kunai a
multi-purpose tool for farming and
masonry but
also one associated with ninjas as it's
more lightweight than the larger more
regulated weapons
and useful for gouging holes and walls
for climbing
this whole functionality is key to hanzo
in his whole bloodline like as he rushes
to be han's men he drops the water
buckets that was the tool that was
critical in the defeat of sub-zero in
the 1995 film you remember
just to signal to us a whole different
approach to the combat in this movie as
hanzo instead combines the kunai with
rope to construct his iconic weapon
that rope lives on as a symbolic
lifeline tethering hanzo
to his future descendants with cole
young and his daughter
sharing corded bracelets in the smoke
and later when cole fights goro he too
uses a tool from a barn
drawn from a bundle of rope and when
cole's akana finally activates it
extends from his daughter's bracelet
oh cool i did
i don't didn't remember that detail that
is pretty much actually
growing out of the bracelet yeah that
actually is pretty sweet
yeah that already has made me appreciate
this movie that much more
the little details i wonder how much of
that is intentional it feels intentional
when you
organize the language of it like this it
feels intentional when you have to see
g and then of course bihan future
sub-zero
played by joe tesleem another martial
arts star known for the raid and fast
and furious six
this whole opening attack on the
compound is very similar to the opening
of the animated film mortal kombat
legends scorpion's revenge
and here the action in gore is really
well choreographed first with the blood
of the guards
squirting upward as the sword goes
through his body until it explodes at
the neck right when it hits the jugular
and then later the blood seeping out of
bihan's knuckles as that ice breaks his
skin
kind of like wolverine's claws
ballet that hanzo performs with the
roped kunai i love this detail how bihan
at first
dodges it but doesn't think to dodge it
when hanzo retracts it scarring
but then later in their final fight
sub-zero shows that he has spent
hundreds of years
thinking about that one mistake so that
when scorpion tries to pull the same
move again
this time he catches it the back of the
pass behind leaves
similar to the way scorpion will leave
sub-zero at the end of this movie then
lord raiden
long time ago oh man says hogan from
thor ragnarok
rescues saving this bloodline that
eventually leads to
our hero cole young played by lewis tan
he continues to don his ancestral colors
with yellow tape around his fists
black and yellow shorts a black and
yellow gym bag strap
he loses the fight by failing to listen
to his daughter
because i should have thrown the
uppercut which he does later the same
advice to him later when he's fighting
goro
and because he listens this time he's
able to get a solid hit on guru then
into the out world where we meet
summoning bihan
now sub-zero to assassinate the
champions of earth realm
while bihan is generally seen in blue
they use darker tones for his costume
here as a nod to be han's noob cybot
form
and cole means trying to say that the
man that took the belt from eddie tobias
uh eddie tobias is a nod to mortal
kombat game creators ed
boon and john tobias that's a real
easter egg
how'd you control the cage strategically
this is what coal applies
to the final battle using raiden's
ability to teleport them anywhere to
control their own
turf also you could see it as a nod to
the final scene where cole has to hide
the cage jax asks about cole's marking
and you actually do see that poster of
the johnny cage
uh movie in the background very early on
i thought like my eyes had deceived me
but there yeah yeah yeah
please at the very end you do see it
yeah clearly but uh yeah when you see
our
movie reaction should be up this week
you'll you'll see you'll see jax asks
about cole's marking here where'd you
get it from
he was born with it what do you mean
it's a birthmark
notice that this dialogue was reversed
from its order back in the trailer
i didn't understand that it's the
birthmark
what do you mean he was born with it
yeah solid fix there so sub-zero
attacks cole and his family and jax lets
them escape while he faces sub-zero and
in the background in the graffiti i love
this it reads down right
plus lp as in downright low punch that's
how you do
sub sub-zero's freeze attack no way
that is that's a neat production detail
they had fun making this wrist joints
and then his elbow joints
showing how bone by bone his arms are
breaking under the ice before both are
ripped off at the shoulder
back in the out world melina shows up
reporting to shangsung
you know what i love about when jax's
arms are ripped off it's like this
moment of just
shock it could have been like ah like
after it happens
yeah but it actually made it more
unsettling when it's just like
yeah well because there's got to be so
much more happening in your mind where
you're like i'm numbed out i'm ice burnt
but also i just witnessed my arms
exploded with me like yeah it's
interesting molina let's finish this
yeah he loves telling people to finish
them of course a nod to his line finish
him in the game
and he decides to send the reptilian
size off using the name versions of
reptile
from the game call themselves sonya
blade has a
classic movie crazy research wall which
is now pretty beyond trope can we stop
putting these in movies hollywood
anyway it documents the history of god
most anyone in real life overall like
characters from the mortal kombat games
like there's this image of the aztec sun
god which you can see is a nod to kotal
khan
the former outworld emperor based on
mayan and aztec mythology there's an
article about a matuka warrior
a nod to nightwolf who you'll know from
annihilation in the other games
that's where i know with a centaur that
you could see as a non-democracy
they've been showing a cracked skull
that maybe could be another visual of
when the x-ray vision shows
the attacks and the bones break but we
meet this movie's comic relief kano
who ends up being the one to defeat
reptiles
yeah this heart rip and the line of
course directly out of the game and then
kano spits on this gnome
marking it for sonia later when she uses
it to stab him through the eye
check off he leads them to raven's
temple he struggles to work his gps
it's actually pretty similar to the way
in the 95 film that sonia's compass
doesn't really work due to that
island's mysterious magnetism but
they're found by liu kang
who leads them into the temple past
these murals
champions including the great kung lao
ancestor did this movie's kung lao the
hooded delia with her husband
argus goro ripping a dude in half and
outworld emperor shao khan
this is making me appreciate the movie
that much more one thing's for sure that
i
i really want them to do a sequel so
because i feel like they would
absolutely i mean for sure be better
than the annihilation one i think they
could deliver a really powerful shout
concept yeah i really hope they do it
man
and on the heels of you know putting at
least a good solid tease in this movie
which i'm sure we'll get to
when cole sees the painting of the fight
between hanzo and bihan he
experiences another vision
yeah you can barely make out scorpion's
voice through the fire saying
unleash me as the wrappings coat the
blade handle
foreshadowing the visual of cole's armor
it's interesting that he's speaking
english here right i'm thinking when
these warriors
he learned it in hell demonic yeah a lot
of times language
changes centuries japanese or mandarin
to the english that cole hears it as
which might also explain the get over
here kano tries to steal the amulet of
shinnok
this is one of the most powerful items
in the mortal kombat universe used by
shanak when he
and the other elder gods waged war
against the one being
it enhances the wielder's powers
drastically
which might give kano a way he could be
resurrected in a future film since i
don't think we actually saw him put it
back after luke kang told him to also
nearby
probably the steel fan of kittens
there's also a no show
in this film but we'll probably appear
in the next one sub-zero attacks liu
kang but kung
lao saves him using his signature hat
throw
and then he pops up from under it with
his ground teleport move
and then shang tsung says but there's so
some mice
which is what he always says after he
sucks out someone's soul as he does to
kung lao later
here in the fighting pit kung lao tells
cole all you can do now is test your
might
yes test your might that's the name of
the minigame for the mortal kombat
series
also a line in the awesome 1995 mortal
kombat
syndrome track liu kang spars with kano
sweeping the leg
it's my go-to move really cute let's see
it drop down again
the only move you know
[ __ ] move that i totally would do all
the time against my older brother
really sucked at this game also i wasn't
very athletic i really wasn't good at
anything
i'm still not really good at anything
except points
to kano for that vertical jump there
which is really the other move i would
just do and repeat when i didn't know
what else to do
liu kane tells cole about his old master
bow right show
uh character from the games master of
the drunken fist and a playable
character in mortal kombat deadly
alliance deception armageddon and mortal
kombat 10. at dinner time kano's rage
activates his arcana his eye laser
ability
notice afterwards how kung lao is
smiling a little bit revealing that this
is
part of his plan to invoke kano's arcana
we meet other out world champions
including hunter dynamics
cabal and of course now cabal is voiced
by damon harriman
who played charles manson in both
tarantino's
hollywood and mine hunter on netflix so
natara doesn't last long kung lao uses
even without a mask he plays creeps
that's his
baby that's his thing i mean even with a
mask he plays creeps you know
kung lao uses another move from the
games turning his hat sideways into this
buzz saw splitting her best fatality
victory yes flawless victory what you
hear when one fighter beats the other
without taking any hits which kugalan
actually does here if you watch it
closely he dodges natara's strike and
then grabs her to steer her directly
into the saw
meanwhile guru attacks cole and his
family and it is
emotional pain being the pain that cole
needs to inspire his arcana as a
descendant of hanzo who lost his family
and you could see that flash breathing
in his eyes as goro is slamming the
truck there
and now with his arcana activated each
of those
amounts to his armor results in less and
less recoil on coal
charging up his armor so that he can
deliver the uppercut that his daughter
wants like black panthers
absorb the energy stabbing through the
eye meanwhile jack sargana gets
activated by lifting the boulder off
sonia
fills out his rebuilt arms into the
thick super strong ones we know and love
and as kung lao's soul gets sucked out
cole pulls liu kang
through the raiden lightning bolt portal
into the void i just love how each bolt
forms what kind of looks like the folds
of a curtain that
creeps in front of them just a really
cool thing
that's awesome space to get out of there
so cole suggests that they split up and
confront each champion in a different
location
including the pit stage the recurring
station
moves this is where jax faces raco as
their fight ends
reiko kind of gets that faded neck roll
that fighter
fatality and jax's fatality
yes you know he fights kano back in the
but this is really demonstrated to me is
their attention to detail on the
gameplay and also the lore
as well because i've heard a lot of
people say like if you don't play mortal
kombat you won't get what this is you
won't get what this is and i was like
look i'm not a religious player of the
of the games but i feel like i followed
it there's so much
little nuggets throughout this whole
movie seeped within the mortal kombat
lore it does go to show that like the
director writer production team that
despite what you think of the overall
execution of how the movie was done they
clearly have an
adoration for the game oh yeah they
clearly put a lot of tlc
into making sure the game stuff was
represented the dagger gets flung loose
going directly into the target board
drawing of sonia holding
kano's severed head maybe this is her
response drawing to his graphic novel
arc that he's always doing
meanwhile against cabal liu kang
performs his famous bicycle bicycle kind
of games
knocks him into the muck where he
finishes him with his classic fire
dragon move fatality
and sonya now with kano's marking blasts
a hole
through melina's body leaving her spine
intact
but also somehow the flesh on our side
of the spine
is clearly blasted away like the blast
curved around the spine a little bit and
the ribs are torched away but not the
meaty tissue around the spine
whatever it looks cool and millennials
sub-zero takes cole's
family they fight not
[Music]
there available shifted to the 1995
theme song
did a lot of yellow belt karate demos to
this and again great fight choreography
here
scorpion sword gets wedged in the ice
and then later he stabs sub-zero with
the chain blade and drags him into that
sword so that
he loves that to pick back up the sword
and then sub-zero cut scorpion releasing
blood and freezing it into a blood
sickle dagger and then stomping
an ice wall into existence just to throw
scorpion into something yeah and then
when hanzo sees cole's frozen family
we intercut with shots of his wife and
his son also frozen
past and present combined as hanzo
realizes that his future bloodline is at
stake here so working together with his
descendants scorpion finishes off
sub-zero with his famous fatality from
the games removing his mask to breathe
fire from his skull
oh yeah and hansa's face actually fully
reverts to that skull
as it returns to the pirates of hell if
you listen closely there's a voice
summoning him there
i call him scorpio oh yes we are likely
hearing the voice of quan chi
a sorcerer from another realm who keeps
scorpion's soul in hell
another person we might meet in the next
film and then in the final scene you all
caught this
i mean i i believe in the actual lore
when it comes to hanzo quan chi is
actually the one responsible for
killing scorpion's family uh and
i believe he actually said if i'm not
mistaken trying to see if i remember
this correctly if i'm
mistaken he like posed this sub-zero and
sub-zero didn't actually
commit this is a big misunderstanding
not in this movie
you all caught this one cole said he is
headed to hollywood in search of a new
champion for their team passing a poster
for
action movie star johnny cage starring
in citizen cage which is a title that he
has brought up in some of the games
i love his cage belt buckle it expresses
a larger than life ego
making me think they might cast a pro
wrestler in the role actually ed boon
is casting wrestler the miz as johnny
cage in the next film
actually speaking of the ego maniacal
apparel this shirt
is actually one of our many great merch
options you can support this channel
directly
by purchasing it at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
rockstars
thanks for watching
yeah yeah they should be able to put
eric voss in the game where
every move all it does is sweep the leg
yep yep yeah and then philip molina
comes in and trains
him in the cutscenes that was wonderful
that made me appreciate this movie a lot
more and the one of the
mortal kombat videos we covered earlier
this week i have said that like i
overall
enjoyed the mortal kombat 95 movie more
than this one but i was like seeing
comments of like well yeah the knight
five has like
this fight is better than any of the
ones in the 2020 i'm like
hold on i think
i think the construction of the fight i
think the choreography of these
the ones here especially the ones
involving scorpion and sub-zero
those top in the ninety-five movies
all right just gotta just make that
stance too cuddly charms aside
let's be real and there seems to be a
little bit more of a genuine
fan appreciation than the 95 one
absolutely yeah coming from behind
paul w s anderson man that dude does not
seem to really
understand the games he's trying to
adapt despite the amount of passion he
shows for them so yeah this does seem at
least informed by people who were all
about this game
alright guys well subscribe to new
rockstars you haven't done so already
keep a lookout for our mortal kombat
reaction should be out within a couple
days yeah hit that like button thank you
to manscape for sponsoring this video
see you guys soon